hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
our readers reach you who wrote in
asking about work-life balance so the
exact question is hi Evan you always
send quite interesting notes to read
that really inspire me so thank you for
that I want to ask one thing would you
please advise me on how an entrepreneur
can balance or cope with personal and
professional life it seems very hectic
to carry on with zeal and satisfaction
if you're happy at work there's
something tense waiting at the personal
front if you're happy with your personal
aspects attention to work please help
warm regards with you thanks to the
question especially as an entrepreneur
it's hard it's really hard to balance
your personal in your business life
because we're so emotionally attached to
our business right a lot of times the
business is an extension of of what we
do what I find really helpful is first
to have a separate space so you may not
be able to afford in the office you know
if you're starting up I like having an
office that I can go to so I have my
home and then I have my office and I
know when I'm at home I'm doing home
stuff and when I'm at the office I can
focus on my business if you're working
from home try to create a separate space
that is just for your office and you
know when you go there you're working
and that's you know you're going to be
focused on that and try to get
everything accomplished and not get too
distracted by your personal things I
find when entrepreneurs have a huge mix
you know you're you know working out of
your kitchen and there's you know kids
coming in and out it's it's just really
frustrating so you want to have a clear
separation the next thing I find that
also helps instead of just physical
separation is have a time separation so
I'll block off hours in my week for work
so I'm going to be in the office for you
know these days and this time and I know
what I'm working on and then just as
important i'll block off things for
personal and family time and I treat
those as important as any really
important business
meeting so i'll try not to book things
on certain days so like saturdays i
won't work i won't go to you know
conferences or trade shows or anything
else because I book that off for family
time you know there's a there's an
exception we'll talk about it and see if
it's really worth it or not but still
usually won't go and that's just a
personal decision but it helps make sure
you have time to do your personal things
as well as your business things it is
easy to get distracted I find at least
for myself if you're having family time
or personal time you come up with an
idea for business you know a lot of the
best ideas you get for your company is
when you're relaxed and your your plane
you know how many great ideas you get in
the shower because you're you're relaxed
right when you're tense and and stressed
out you probably can cope with a lot of
good ideas so if you're playing with
your kids or if you're just relaxing or
hanging out with friends you'll probably
get some great ideas for your business
and what I try to do then is just write
it down you know take some notes send an
email to myself and then move on and can
be able to continue on with with
whatever was doing for that day I try
not to get distracted you know with the
phone and answer an email that come in
you know I've set time so when I'll do
emails so just having clear boundaries
between your personal life and your
business life I find really helps I know
it can still be hard but try to remember
that you know when you're spending your
time with your family your friends
that's your time with your family and
friends and shut up everything else and
don't bring your work home with you and
when you do get a great idea yo don't
ignore it i don't want you to lose
awesome ideas to your company but send
yourself a quick email or take a note so
you can come back to it when you are
focused on your work that being said
it's still hard you're going to work
crazy hours as an entrepreneur
especially to launch it and you do want
to make sure that you still have some
time for your friends and family because
otherwise you're going to burn up and
it's very calling or entrepreneurs will
spend crazy hours at the beginning and
burn out and quit their company and
you'll have much more success by working
less hours but keeping at it
is something every day to grow a
business you'll be more successful and
you'll also be a lot happier so
hopefully that answers your question
thank you everybody for watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below make you want to do more of
these for you and I love you have to
think if you want to comment about this
video or if you have a question about
your own business feel free to leave in
the comments section below I always read
those I love seeing them come in it
makes my makes my day when I see new
comments coming in the videos I know get
back to you as well so thank you and
we'll see you on the next episode
you